[BLANK_AUDIO]
Ilya you mentioned the Critical Rendering Path. It sounds pretty important.
>> It is. The Critical Rendering Path is the sequence of steps
that the browser goes through to convert the HTML, CSS, and JavaScript
into actual pixels on the screen. And, if we can optimize that,
then we can make our pages render fast, which makes for happier users.
>> Cool. So what's involved in it?
>> So, this diagram captures all of the essentials.
First we grab the HTML and we start building the
document object model. We then have to fetch the CSS and build the
CSS object model. We combine those two to create the Render Tree. Then
we have to figure out where everything goes on the page, which is
the Layout step. And then finally we can paint pixels on the actual screen.
>> Wait a second though, you only
talked about HTML and CSS, what about JavaScript?
>> right, yeah, so that's a big important part of the performance
puzzle. But before we get there let's talk about, how we construct
a document object model, the CSS object model, and then
we'll talk about how JavaScript affects the actual rendering pipeline.
>> Okay, that sounds great.